[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
my dad is one of my most favorite people
on this earth because he is gentle and
kind and it's genuine
[Music]
my name is pearl Pearson jr.
do you have a name sign pearl
and I love jokes I love making people
laugh
[Music]
my brain was damaged from all of the
blows I had been hit and I almost
blacked out my eyes were damaged it was
difficult for me to breathe you know I
was trying to tell them to stop I was
choked up I couldn't breathe my head I
was dizzy because of the the trauma that
was happening I called over the fetal
position just trying to make it stop
before that I had gone to a deaf coffee
event at Starbucks and they closed at
10:00 and I left about 9:30 I said bye
to everybody and I left and we were
driving and then there were some police
lights behind me I didn't know where we
were going so I pulled over and the
police pulled up behind me I have a
placard in my car that explains that I'm
deaf and I have communication needs so I
was getting ready to get that I had my
hands on the wheel and the policeman
came up with his gun drawn around the
side of the car and he I rolled down the
window and the police started talking to
me and I pointed my ear to say I'm deaf
just just a second and I was going to
reach for that paper that placard that I
had that explains I'm deaf and when I
reached down his fist came through the
window and then his other hand grabbed
my wrist
[Applause]
when they pulled his arm like that it
dislocated his shoulder so at that
moment before I even got out of the
vehicle his right arm is completely out
of socket so they finally got the door
open and got the seatbelt off and pulled
me out onto the ground and then we're
beating me and the police say that it
was seven minutes but it really felt
more like ten or fifteen they at one
point had him in a chokehold we learned
that he had a concussion my dad believed
that he would die and that he was going
to die I was yelling I'm deaf I'm deaf
and I was angry and I was upset trying
to make them understand and I tried to
talk and I tried to tell them but they
kept they kept beating me they kept
hitting and so I just had to go back
into a fetal position I was screaming I
was screaming you can't follow commands
if you can't hear them you can't put
your arms behind your back when you've
got one arm dislocated and hanging out
and the muscles that are attached to it
torn it's not physically possible to do
that
[Music]
I wanted to descry but we had work to do
and I needed to hold it together
his eyes were swollen and it was like
blood he would have been looking at the
possibility of losing his eyesight you
know he already had you know doesn't
have his access to hearing things and to
lose his eyesight too would be just I
don't even know how to say it you know
my my dad I guess is the nicest most fun
gentle guy and I didn't understand how
this could be done to him if this thing
has happened to other deaf individuals
in other states and there have been
others that have ultimately died what's
the address here man we heard gunshots
we walked out 57
[Music]
police officer shot and killed the deaf
man in Oklahoma City 35 year old mag
deal Santos shot and killed in his front
yard and they were at his home
investigating a hit and run crash
involving his father
neighbors say besides being
hearing-impaired he was also mentally
impaired we won't be able to understand
police violence in this day and age if
we don't understand the connections that
exist between race and disability based
discrimination law enforcement said he
had taken a very threatening posture and
that he was about to use his walking
stick in some sort of harmful manner the
video that is complete seems to
contradict that story based on the
footage provided by community members
mag Dale Sanchez was actually retreating
from law enforcement and this completely
contradicts law enforcement a story
about what occurred several people
mentioned that they had eye contact with
law enforcement when they told law
enforcement that he was deaf and that he
could not hear them and that law
enforcement still went ahead and shot
and tased him lieutenant Lindsay an
officer Barnes's actions were lawful
reasonable and not excessive you don't
need to hear to know what these officers
are saying to you
[Laughter]
[Music]
I've authorized felony charges on the
father of mr. Sanchez for the felony
hit-and-run for leaving the scene of an
injury accident he also did not have a
driver's license and he was not insured
so who'd be charged with all of those
crimes
[Music]
dad did not learn ASL American Sign
Language until he eventually ended up at
Oklahoma School for the Deaf after it
was desegregated due to segregation of
education systems there were full sign
languages developed in black deaf
communities all around the nation
[Music]
I have to believe that law enforcement
officers in general are trying to do the
right thing
my husband's in law enforcement remember
others in law enforcement it's really
frustrating to realize that not all
truth is brought forward that dashcam
video that everybody has seen in the
media is from that first car well
there's a second car that has dashcam
video that should have captured what the
police actually did we have been told
that the trooper that was in that second
car turned the dashcam video off I'm
kind of hesitant now to roll down my
window all the way with the police I
might crack it and put the sign that
says that I'm deaf there but I don't
want to roll down my window all the way
anymore there's a fear for sure that
this might happen again and it shouldn't
it should never happen again there needs
to be training there needs to be
education I mean so there's just no
excuse for it in this day and age please
need to understand what being deaf means
when we move our hands it's not a threat
it's signing it's how we communicate I
wish that they understood that that that
wouldn't cause them to panic
this video is part of a larger series on
the deaf community here are some of the
incredible people featured in this
series
subscribe to catch all of these amazing
stories on this season of untold America
and let us know what community we should
cover next